[Music]
Father, it's tough. There's a battle 3 kilometers away. How
can we even know what's going on? Yes, about 10
humans are being
swarmed by dozens of monsters.
Hurry up! We're being attacked by monsters 3 kilometers away.  Yes, you
guys go ahead. We
won't make it in time if we continue like this. I'll go too. It's
dangerous. It's okay. I've got a private tutor.
[Music]
Protect this place. It's completed. A
child like this...  You can't come to that place. It's impossible. If it's
magic, we'll involve the knights.
[Music] You're the
only one left.
[Music] Are you
okay? Don't
go near the carriage. Stop there. I'm
sorry, I'm late. Hiroshi Frontier,
Garmfan Silford Gracia's third son,
Cain.  My name is Von Silford.